我覺得今天主要是講四個問題
就是現在這個市場實踐裡面
我們關注的第一個就是現在到底處於什麼樣一個狀態
因為市場上有很多人說要調整嘛
然後這個調整是什麼情況下有可能會調整
我們的Fundamental Setup從宏觀到微觀來說
是一個什麼樣的狀態
我覺得這是第一個問題
第二個就是如果在這個狀態下面
那麼我們持有什麼樣的投資標的地會比較好
大概什麼樣的倉穩
是繼續去追那些程序光不快
那這個我不是很建議之前
那麼還是說我們持有盈利為主的東西
那這個跟現在市場3F比較有關係
然後第三個就是回調的時候怎麼買
然後回調的概率其實有還是挺大的
因為我們上週好像就講到過
可能會發生一些政治上的事件對吧
那在政治上的事件到底發生什麼樣的情況
什麼樣的政治事件
為什麼會背後有這樣的驅動
這個都不知道的
所以如果發生回調
那麼再回調的時候買什麼樣的東西
其實第四個我想探討的問題是說
因為我們對於前面
今年是一個增長
就是我覺得是個牛市
是個牛市年對於美股來說是個牛市年
對於大部分風險資產中國不太確定嘛
因為中國畢竟中央會經這兩天在賣股票
那是他們空的盤
所以中國不太確定的情況下
我覺得是Decouple的美國的Decouple的增長年
就是美國會表現好於全世界其他地方
跟25年的Sara不太一樣
但是同時也是一個因為大選
中期選舉嘛
從事它也是一個波動的商場的年
波動的牛市
那在波動牛市裡面
什麼樣的風險防控標的
就是兩說我現在要去Hatch a terrorist
給那種我們防止的
不是說我今天買了股票可能會跌個5%對吧
你怕的是說它大盤給你調個15% 20%
然後這種情況下
什麼樣的東西去防止這樣的資產
就是做一個對沖
然後去防止這個資產的下調
所以我覺得今天主要是討論這四個話題
所以可能時間
我可能不一定講完我就下周講
然後首先我覺得宏觀上來說
這個我覺得沒有變化
上周的話
其實基本上經濟數據也是繼續應徵這一點
就是你會看到那個
包括我們待會會結合10年期的國家來說這個事情
10年國家大概是怎麼走是吧
然後本質上是這樣就是一開始的時候
就月初的時候就星期初的時候
創六開始攻擊那個又開始攻擊Fed了
然後中間出來的CPI其實應徵了美國
就是我們叫三個主題
第一個叫disinflation
第二個就是low employment
我的就業不是很好
然後我的增長是moderate是說不錯的
就是說我有通脹的風險在下降
然後就業相對比較緩慢
但是經濟增長還算可以
這個大概是美國今年的setup
這個setup下面就是非常難發生
就是這是一個牛式的setup
因為聯儲相對來說會比較比較鬆軟一些
而且JPOW下來
那個Trump推一個人上去
現在不管最後折衷是CAPMAN上去還是誰上去
我覺得會多降一次戲
它不是說讓美國無限的像Trump說的一樣
我可以降到什麼很低
而是說我可以多降一次戲
那麼再總結來說
其實這個美聯儲都是算偏軟的
而且因為inflation也比較低
所以美聯儲本身的狀態就可以是比較偏軟
所以這個是我們宏觀經濟上的一個大的setup
這個setup我覺得是一個我們講過很多次
我覺得現在沒有特別大的變化
如果有變化我跟大家講
這個是很多市場的不少的市場投資人的一個公開的認可
那麼我覺得這是主線
然後還有條紅彎上的腐線
是Trump要幹嗎
Trump要幹嗎
因為今年是一個
今年不能光看金價
今年還得看政治的
那個因為要做中期選舉吧
所以你可以回過Trump在過去兩年裡面
他要去說我幹了什麼
我獲得了我幹了什麼
然後我做這些東西能夠在中期選舉的時候
然後就有脾氣運營的選票
那麼在Trump的這個狀態裡面
其實有三件事情
它是主要的指針的要點
第一件事情是移民
但是ID這次在那個在Ninja Minnesota
做出來的這個打死人的這個事情
其實讓那個移民非常難講
比如你在路上可能把那個反移民的人給打死
不管因為什麼原因
他是撞警察也好
或什麼也好
他這個事情
他是很難作為一個政績去到處去吹的
而且他其實並沒有做出什麼政績來
所以他回過頭
他就會放到一個是他重述貿易關係
這個中間確實是有一些貿易協定簽訂的
包括中國貿易
包括跟日本貿易協定
歐洲那些國家
所以重述貿易關係
還有個就是重述行業
就是他要說我重述政績的行業
比方說他唯一一個人可以拿出來
講的就是英特爾
英特爾他投了錢
其實他什麼也沒錯
他投了錢人家本來就要恢復了
英特爾這個公司本來就快要起飛了
然後他抄了個頂
說他這個WIMP
Wanderman Joint Billions of Dollars
然後說他把那個資金製造
那個金援製造又帶回了美國
但這些肯定是不夠多的
所以呢
市場可能出現的volatility
就在Trump去Maintain
維持他的tariff
然後Trump去給公司施壓
我們在上週其實看到兩個
比較詭異的動詳題
第一個是軟件去爆點
軟件在上週四上週五的時候爆點
第二個就是在金融行業
金融我們看到金融的機報
那麼並沒有
機票並沒有什麼特別大的問題
然後NL都還不錯
然後但是金融行業
那個有一些波動
那麼這個金融行業的波動
背後就是Trump對公司進行施壓
然後說了
我希望快利卡完這事
因為快利卡完這事
整個行業就被9M抹掉了
信用卡怎麼可能10%
信用卡的貸款利率
在中國可能都不止10%
你10%連成本都可怕不過來
你中間還有各種各樣的取消
取到費用
所以這些東西
所以他可能會在這兩個方向去施壓
這個是他執政的要點
就是除了我們這個table上看到的
這個上週的經濟數據
我們一直在講的是
完全是非政治的經濟
和臉上政治的可能會發生的波動
就Trump的
這個是他的fundamental setup
他的背景
但是我們也同時瞭解到兩件事情
第一個他沒有議會
在美國總統不是想辦法
就可以幹嘛的
那個包括關稅
他其實沒有通過議會
他是用了緊急法案
所以現在最高法院
對阿伊帕的判決
是隨時都可能發生
我的感說是
如果最高法院脫了更長時間
可能會關稅
更多的部分被保留下來
因為現在大家爭議越大
越有可能脫
因為有可能脫的話
他又可能對Trump稍微好一點
但是其實Anymanian老師
任何時候他都有可能會判決
那麼現在如果你只看
跑里馬凱這些賭博網站的話
那個Trump的書面還是比較大的
那麼但是我是覺得今年
包括他現在對Greenland的時候
我要給歐洲加水
這個到底對市場有多大的衝擊
你也不知道
就是說
我們可以看一個這個表
就是他對於歐元區這些加稅的國家
就是這個是
假設他就是真的是加2%的萬稅
而且是能夠持續下來
他不是在演戲的話
大概是10 to 20 basis point
對於這些國家影響
就是也沒有很大
就是這麼一個東西
那麼他為了維持關稅
為了維持他所謂的
因為你關稅維持不住
他後面所謂的貿易協定
其實全部維持不住
他的貿易協定都是靠關稅而來的
所以他手上沒有武器
人家都不理他了
其他國家都不會去徵收他
所以他需要去證明自己
重述了貿易關係
他要維持關稅
那麼他甚至說
我把關稅的錢退出來
做second physical package
就是做fabality
就是等於是給大家給老百姓發錢
他做這個事情
那麼不管他是給老百姓發錢
還是做fabality
做那個mortgage
做那個房屋底下大款
試圖把這個利率拉低
不管用哪種方法
他都要通過議會
現在他都通過議會
議會至少可以給你菲律巴斯特到下一次
就是你如果要再做一次財政支出的話
至少這種事情
議會肯定可以給你菲律巴斯特到下一次
就是到中級選舉之後
而且現在看來議會中級選舉
你能拿下的概率就非常非常的低
所以我們把Trump在這個中間的行動
就是我們宏觀了賽料
這是實實在在的
那條虛線就政治上特朗普
或者是總統的這個想做什麼事情
可以給市場到來的老亂
或者是給市場到來的這個波動
我們認為是條虛的
因為他所有做的事情全部在演戲
你可以這樣認為
就是他做的所謂的行業
比方說他給那個健康行業給人家壓要去
你看上去是壓到了
但是其實對於藥公司的影響沒有那麼大
就是大家跟你妥協一下
就有一些要跟你講一講
就是演一下戲配合你演一下
然後他可能給半導體行業要補還
或者要幹嘛
或者要給你要把資源堆給Intel
那Intel肯定可以擊飛
但是你要在半導體行業
你要把大家晶圓場全部搬到美國去
或者你要做這樣的事情
他其實在這個這麼短時間裡面
能夠達成的東西是非常有限
那麼在行業裡面
你要給金融行業要求他10%的信用卡的利率
那你可以去給這些行業去施壓
但是大家都知道你沒有立法的能力
你沒有辦法實質地對我造成任何的影響
所以你能夠做的也就是
我就是面子上給你妥協一下
所以你可以把我為什麼掛了一個drama的頭像
就是你可以把今年的波動認為是drama
他在那裏演戲
他對市場造成的影響其實實質上是非常小的
他要去推出2nd physical package
這個可能性也會很小
實實在在的實驚忌的幾半面
這個是我們現在宏觀上的一個狀態
就是我們先說什麼樣的狀態
第二你說一下微觀上的狀態
然後影春道講一下
這個當然是OBAI的自己的一個planetation說的事情
就是從GbG把的那個算力
算力是現在市場上最最缺的
不管你說是缺存儲
背後也是因為缺了算力的時候缺存儲
那個算力是整個市場最最缺少的東西
就是token的需求和算力
這個是我覺得未來幾年永恆不變的一個矛盾
就是長期缺貨
所以我們說半導體上面
你任何一個人說缺貨
你就先信
要么不信要么就要么不信要信早信
就是你反正他只要說缺貨
你就可以
我絕對可以說行
但是OBAI是有一個
我們覺得就是
你可以看他planetation中間
講到他一個很亮點
就是從算力上來說
計瓦從23年0.2到25年的1.9
但是他的那個revenue是增加了10倍
就是算力的需求當然很缺了
他的算力增加了13倍
但是他的收入增加了10倍
所以你說現在狀態是什麼
AI的公司背後推動
最最後面去購買算力這些
最後最終的買家
其實是OBAI
Andopia
Andopia好像是昨天剛剛3500億在融資
然後他們都不會缺錢
他們都能融得到錢
所以那麼在市場
那麼他們能融到錢
而且他們的效率在提高
就相當於說
這些是新新的生產力
我們華爾街的理解永遠是
我們需要
比方說我造鐵路
鐵路能帶來新的效率
然後能帶來新的生產力
你已經能帶來東西在哪裡呢
那麼我們沒有看到
所以我們覺得AI有泡沫
對吧
但是其實並不是
我好像我上兩周也講過這個問題
AI本質上
它是新的生產力
取代久的生產力
它不一定創造新的東西
但它把你老的給幹掉了
為什麼你上周看到那個軟件
跌那麼多
大家怕嗎
軟件萬一這些傢伙們到時候都被AI取代
這件事情不會在很短時間發生的
軟件的Earning其實是可靠的
就是它可能在一年兩年裡面
這些包括CIM
我說它
我一直說CIM就死路一條
最後要么被
要么被那個Microsoft幹掉
要么被OpenAI直接幹掉
要么被Microsoft用OpenAI的接口給幹掉
對吧
這個是我們的認知
它的Earning會下降
它的這些東西沒有那麼容易賣
它的SARS沒有那麼容易賣
因為有語音
大家把數據傳到語音上
語音廠本身就可以買
或者是AI公司給你接口
直接買都有可能
但是它的時間是要時間效應的
那本質上來說
這些都有可能
甚至會被侵吞掉
所以我們說
AI是從哪裡拿到的資源
那哪裡拿到的這個
我們說Earning盈利
它是從現業
它是代表一個新的行業
去幹掉舊的行業
舊的行業裡面會大部分死掉
這個是侵吞或者是
吃上份額的這麼一個遊戲
那麼在這個遊戲裡面
最缺的
我覺得還是
就是說這個最缺的還是算力
所以我們說
這個微觀上的賽拉
就是所有跟算力相關的
我們說半導體
他們都是會長期
你認為是供應市場
從TSMC開始到AV店
這是賣房市場
就是我最終能夠生產多少東西
能賣多少
那麼在這個裡面
最最核心的是台積電的現場
就台積電能夠產多少卡
然後它產這些卡
你可以認為全部會被賣掉
然後它把這些卡分配給誰
那分配給主要是因為它
然後第二個是阿巴狗
阿巴狗估值比因為它高很多
那麼第二個是阿巴狗
所以像英偉達的話
他們的這個二領是確定性
我再說
他確定性非常非常高
但是市場現在
最在微觀的敘事上面
微觀的這個狀態上面
不是這樣子的
市場現在在微觀的狀態是說
你可以把它分成兩件事情
第一個是講故事
我們叫敘事講故事
第二個是二領就盈利
盈利最最確定
十大是增長
最確定性最高的公司
敘事最差
增長了最少
或者是甚至在電
這就是為代表的就是英偉達
然後那個講故事
講的相對來說
不是很好的故事
然後盈利基本上
我認為沒有那麼確定性
沒那麼高
但基本上沒有什麼問題
比方說Microsoft
那個微軟
微軟就屬於
微軟屬於盈利確定性
還是比較高的
就是你這麼想
大家都在後面要去買算力
買算力這些人都能容得到錢
所以他們會持續去買
Token買算力
那麼這些人還是要去用到
微軟的這個微軟的這個語音服務
語音也是算力
也是缺的
那微軟二領不錯的情況下
它的估值性20多倍P比英偉達好一點
因為英偉達今年
可能增長80%
去年增長了60%
然後它的股價漲了40%
今年增長80%
到現在股價第二
就今年比較確定的到年底增長
大概70%到80%之間
然後它的增速還在提高
但股價再點
就是Microsoft的至少比
比那V典英偉達的好一點
但是它沒有故事
然後呢
它在就是它在
就是Ning比較確定
但是它也是在點
然後漲的是什麼
漲的是那些蓄勢很好
Ning還沒看到的
就比方說光模塊
比方說存儲
就這個市場狀態
在微觀上的市場狀態
我雖然說我們大基調
是個紅灣上的牛市大基調
但是在微觀上的這種狀態下面
我覺得是不可能持久的
這裡面只有兩種可能
就是不可能說
我存儲和光模塊繼續漲
你可以把存儲光模塊
甚至CPU全部當成
GPU英偉達的供貨上
就它不存在
它們都不存在
因為英偉達的盈利不行的話
就是大家對算力的總需求
是出問題的
一列一家競爭的事情
因為最終因為它拿了
Colors一般大部分的現成
那就是它如果是發生存貨了
那整個AI需要的算力
它不是這樣增加的
就不是三倍三倍三倍這樣增加的
對吧
那個台積電的CAPEX投入是40
Token的需求是三倍三倍三倍
就是你Token的需求和
就我們剛剛講的供需矛盾的
總基調變成變化了
那還有存儲什麼時間
存儲也不會好的
所以我認為
就是說現在你K-Shift的變化
只有兩種可能
第一種就是大家
如果大氣調不變的話
那就是大家一起下調
然後該固持恢復的互不恢復
在這過程中一起下調的時候
像英偉達這種盈利非常確定的
就是能夠低的幅度很小
不會那麼大
但是你去追進廣播化和存儲
可以把你腰斬
我是覺得這兩個行業
在今年你大概都會看到腰斬
腰斬沒什麼
腰斬到年底還是會長下去
因為畢竟大家都缺貨了
就是它敘事一旦不好
你現在敘事吹的那些嘴字
那個失職就會調整
所以K-Shift不太可能發生
繼續拉大的可能
只有兩種
第一個掉下去一起漲
第二種就是減刀茶恢復
就是該漲的漲
該跌跌跌
這兩種都有可能吧
最後我覺得取決於會不會發生
宏觀上的風險
那個宏觀上風險比方格林蘭比較小
因為現在宏觀上發生這些風險
你也不能光看news看發新聞
因為現在大家對於
你看我這邊還列一個
對於歐洲到底影響有多少
這高盛率算了
但是你看市場上
現在沒有人在計算這些東西
因為市場上
大家在4月份的時候都在計算
我最終關稅到了40%
對Global全球的經濟影響對多少
對美國通脹
對於美國
我們也當時在算這個
對於美國經濟影響多少
現在大家其實都知道
你這傢伙很有可能明天就變瓜了
你可能就是炒破股票了
Trump我說
所以不一定那麼take seriously
所以最終影響多少
要看市場反應
但是他不持續的出各種東西
因為他需要選票
他需要中期選舉的選票
他現在移民說不了了
他只能去說行業和送出貿易關係
在這裡面說行業
我就額外說一個
他有可能會對Intel造成利好
因為他所有做的事情裡面
幾乎只有這個能拿出來講
就沒有什麼特別的可以拿出來講
然後最後我這邊認證一下
AI的生產力和美國宏觀的
我們常講宏觀的就是disinflation
然後moderate growth這樣一個呼應一下
首先你可以看得到
美國最大的四家銀行
AI的最終的使用方式是誰
有沒有提高效率
這個就是說
是不是你們自己吹自己玩
就是你半導體行業和那個行業
自己吹自己玩
其實並不是
你可以看到
從JP Mokendo Bank of American Citibank
Westfago
四個最大的銀行
他們每年花百分之十的
revenue investment tax
在高科技上投資
但這個是有很多
比如說他們用VMWF
要更高速的這個
更高速的這個網絡
但是中間很重要的部分是AI
然後你可以看到Bank
現在銀行說
銀行為什麼現在看好
就是前一段時間為什麼看好銀行
你一個百分之十信用卡的事情跑掉
這個沉不沉
還不好說
所以到沉不沉
不好說
但是銀行為什麼前一段時間看好
因為銀行一直在
就是經濟這兩年
一直在generating operating leverage
operating leverage是什麼意思
就是我的收入和我的那個支出
之間的差
就是說我相當於
我減少了我的開支
開支銀行主要是Hackon
是人嘛
所以你滑掉JP Mokendo
就除掉JP Mokendo
它有點expanding
但是除了JP Mokendo
你滑幾個銀行
這個Hackon一年是減少5%
所以這個是哪來的
其實這中間有很大的
是AI的效率提升
你可以回頭看我們當時
當我不在銀行
我在投資銀行
我們以前狗門
狗門不在這個上面
它這個主要是看那個商業銀行
那個
狗門不在上面
但是我們以前每天工作到
每個星期工作100個小時吧
然後寫PPT
搞這些東西
我發覺我以前做的這些事情
當我第一年
第二年在投行
按的這些事情
99%
現在電腦一鍵就可以生成
所以很大的就
Aless不需要
我開個會寫個會議機
要寫半天要寫了
很好化成PPT
現在電腦一秒鐘就給你生成
那一秒鐘不行
一分鐘就給你生成
所以這些工作
其實很大程度上
被取代銀行的效率在提高
你說AI提高算力
然後做模型
它的收入在增加的同時
收入哪裡來的
擠掉的是某些人的蛋糕
對吧
有些銀行就不需要供那麼多人了
那而且後續還有很大的空間
因為你看銀行
現在前四家銀行
就六家銀行總的增加了10%
平均化10%
在投在TAC上面
但是前四家是後面兩家的10倍
那這個就是這樣的一個狀態
所以我們說後面的銀行
金融機構
金融服務機構
我想說快捷失誤
問題是律師所
律師所
那個快捷失誤所這些
然後Consultant的資訊
這都是配很高的
好像在美國
能夠取代的效率其實提高
都還剛剛開始開花
沒有怎麼開花
所以我們上次講到
就是說你什麼樣的公司
會是比較好的
我們講說誰在應用AI
AI是在提升效率
對
AI在提升它本身的效率
然後我們再去看
它自己做出AI的工具
能夠提升社會的效率
能夠被別人使用
先看它能不能提升自己的效率
為什麼銀行漲
銀行在提升自己的效率
對於這個行業來說
我覺得最有限來說
基本上AI大量的生產力提高
還剛好開始
所以這個本質的setup
就是說了
我們在微軟上面的一個K shape
這個是一個危險的信號
就是你在K往上走的那些敘事上面
因為一般來說
市場是這樣的
我覺得華爾街邏輯通常是對的
就是說一般來說
我們蓄勢好的公司
慢慢要取代
蓄勢不好的公司
所以蓄勢不好的
你雖然二令高
但是你以後會被取代
那麼你的估值就應該比較低
殺你的估值
然後蓄勢好的公司
我為了以後可以增加
所以華爾街通常說
給你更高的皮
給你更高的預期
給你更高未來預期
但是現在在半導體上
肯定是不合適的
因為半導體上
他們是直接相關
也就是你認為
他們是細細相關的
就是皮質不純毛疆煙腐
這樣的一個關係
所以這樣的一個剪刀插拉開
是不合適的
就最簡單問你
MU今年能不能拿到80%的增長
75到80%
能當嗎
你的股價的上升
已經超過了你二令的上升了
你就這個是最簡單的
就是你的股價上升幅度
肯定是超過你二令的上升幅度
因為那個人沒到
你拿這個比較
所以我是覺得
這個剪刀插要恢復
那麼市場會不會下條
不知道的情況下
我們最後講一下
我認為什麼東西
去做一個對沖是比較合理的
就是首先你要做一個
tell risk catch
發生的是至少兩個方差以外的風險
就是比方說
每股跌個百分之十是我
是這種風險
為什麼會發生
不知道
我現在沒有看到
紅丸上會發生的原因
但是頭穿也沒有很勇氣
但是你怕它發生
再看這個標的
我覺得是十年期利率
就是十年期利率
我記得我們我去年年底
講是在4.15到4.2
因為4.15到4.2
對應的是去年的國債供應量
國債這個東西跟供應量很相關
然後跟risk on risk off很相關
就是當國債的利率
就是利率本身對市場影響
沒有那麼大
但是利率的波動
就volatility
對市場影響更大
這個是很厲害
但是高利率通常來說
對於風險資產不是特別好
那麼如果你認為
紅丸經濟出問題
那麼在一旦出問題的時候
國債是必然下跌的
這跟00年的時候
其實Jot Solos他們在00年的時候
那個
Kwantum放虧了很多錢
最後但是那個
Type bubble快解鎖的時候
他們最後把錢賺回來
也是靠了他們去浪國債
那麼今年為什麼國債利率
我覺得基本上是一個封頂狀態
就是我們說
我從24年開始到25年
我都是覺得國債這個東西
像希西弗斯推石頭一樣
就是你怎麼跌下來
他就會怎麼升上去
因為大量的供應量極大
這個是國債的基調
而且會很長時間維持這個基調
所以當時我24年的時候
就說total return結束了
就是長期的這個國債收益
我一邊拿債的資本收入
一邊拿債的這個哭泡收入
這個事情解鎖
就是買債長期做投資
不不是一個在美國很好交易
但是今年至少在今年這段時間
是一個反轉
就是流動性相對來說比較寬於
就是國債供應量供應量來說比較寬於
然後Demount能夠買國債的錢
也會被放出來
這個主要跟我們放了大概
美國大概四五萬億吧
銀行可以擴表
就是你說的那個
銀行對於資本金的要求改變
可能會多個四五萬億吧
然後我實話釋出了
所以對於債的長端的需求是可以
不會讓債貼特別多的
然後第二個就是說
你現在還在pricing
什麼2nd physical package
就是川普搞這些事情
那麼1月份你的預算案能不能通過
都不太好說
所以就說國債的供應量
其實並沒有那麼大
甚至你在1月份1月底的時候
如果再搞出來
那個政府關門或者什麼之類的事情
其實也是讓國就是
這個對債都是往下的一個動力
但是更加重要的是它的Volatility
它的波動力很低
意味著你去買Option
去買Swapion
成本很低吧
就是你這樣想
就是如果你在這個位置去買一個
Automoney的Swapion
如果國債往下動20個點
大概收一個50倍左右
這個是Swapion的這個售價
所以你這個非常比較符合
就是買一個彩票
你可能你的倉務裡面1%0.5%
你買一個彩票
但是如果是整個大盤是發生劇烈下跌的話
這個彩票能讓你MultipleMultiple
就是幾十倍的收益
我是覺得如果說
對沖一下調整的風險
因為現在的風險是兩邊
一邊是可能會發生政治性的調整
你也不知道發生什麼事情
第二邊是你比較確定的到了年底
這些公司要很好
要增長很快
所以你如果錯過了
你這個倉務
你錯過的倉務你都拿不住
就是你空倉你空倉都拿不住
到年底它會長到你瘋掉
長到你這個
有可能會長到你的那個心態暴漲
然後你再高點再追進去
然後再被調整
這個是很有可能的
所以我是非常不建議空倉
就是現在那個對於比較
盈利非常確定那些票
你可以放就
我覺得就是現在就回過他說
你現在買什麼
回調買什麼
然後風險控制怎麼做
風險控制
我覺得Swapping是個很好的工具
4.2的國債利率
現在我覺得在這位置是比較安全的
我絕對如果說一定要進入倉務的話
在國債上
我會leaning into long duration
long duration
就是我覺得會往下調
這個是一個
它方向向往下調
第二個
我很低
賣Swapping
第二個就是現在持有什麼
我覺得是持有
包括比較扛大的盈利比較好的公司
就是不要去買續市型的
然後買康達
康達的公司一樣會漲很多的
像英偉的
因為它的earning是增長
活生生增長80%
今年80%是個不低的手眼
一年是個很不錯的手眼
它如果漲到
就去年它沒燒到的20%
因為它增長了60%
但是股價漲到40%
今年它要增長70%到80%
如果它恢復到所有東西都漲上去的話
其實是有很大的空間的
然後回調買什麼
回調我不太經意去買廣播環
因為這個東西
續市是不好說的
續市你像風一樣吹在哪裡是哪裡
所以我個人覺得
就是說買續市還沒出來的
比方說CPU
就是如果回調的話
就買AMD和Intel
這是我個人的感覺
然後說下去美元指出
美元兌銳了
美元兌讓我們有很強的觀點
對日元的話
我覺得基本上今年
DAX對於美元來說
是美元是一個注底的事情
就是去年美元的指數
大概跌到7%
然後今年的話
我覺得美元繼續下跌的空間
不是特別大
這個上周我其實強過
就我覺得人民幣
這是比較管理的貨幣
但是美元現在不完全是使用美元
是一個美股美元
就是它是一個風險資產美元
就是今年我覺得大的宏觀的基調
是資產重新Decouple
就是你認為25年是re-coupled
就是大家都跟著美元開始漲了
其實EM的國家漲比美國還多
然後24年 23年基本上都是美元
就是一制度美元和美國資產一制度
我覺得今年除了中期選舉的
一些波動以外
其實在波動中間該出去的錢
其實出去的不少
後面其實我個人感覺是今年
今年和明年吧
就是或者明年至少上半年
這個是重新美國一制度秀的這麼一個行情